while America struggles to flatten the
curve Australia's Prime Minister says
his country could be fully reopened by
July this morning he announced an easing
of the nation's lockdown well the
population of around 25 million
Australia has reported just over 6900
coronavirus cases and fewer than a
hundred deaths Holly Williams reports on
why the country has fared relatively
well surf stopped again in the land down
under as Australians return to a
socially distanced temperature checked
sanitized version of normality the
country of around 25 million has lost
fewer than a hundred lives to the new
virus and the number of new cases slowed
to a trickle weeks ago it could be
partly down to the climate the virus
arrived in the southern hemispheres
summer but Australia's also been praised
for its decisive action the country
closed its doors to nearly all
foreigners in mid-march with returning
residents doing mandatory quarantine in
hotels paid for by the government they
wrapped up testing early and now there's
a smartphone app that allows the
government to trace infections it's
vital to know quickly if you've come in
contact with someone it's raised privacy
concerns but over five million people
have downloaded it agreeing with their
prime minister Scott Morrison that by
refusing to they'd put themselves at
risk it's like not putting on sunscreen
to go out into the Blazing Sun in spite
of the fact that Australians like to you
know think of themselves as being rebels
who don't like Authority actually when
it comes to the crunch we do what we're
told
Waleed Aly is a journalist and
commentator who works for an Australian
network owned by Viacom CBS the result
has been an incredible flattening of the
almost a crushing of the curve here in
Australia and we're very proud of it
four months ago Prime Minister Morrison
was heckled on the street for his
response to devastating bush fires now
after setting up a bipartisan national
cabinet to fight the virus his approval
ratings are up 30 percent since January
this is the best that Australian
politics has worked for well forever
really forever I mean in my lifetime I
don't remember seeing esperen politics
work as well as this in some countries
the new virus has pushed people further
apart but as Australia opens up its
people seem to have been bound closer
together for CBS this morning Holly
Williams maybe with some lessons there
for this country